hello and welcome back to another video
by simply learn are you looking to
advance your career as a business
analyst well you have come to the right
place in today's fast-paced world having
the proper credentials to stand out is
essential we will discuss the road map
to become a business analyst in 2023 we
will be discussing business analysis and
what business analysts do and also we
will see the path of your career apart
from this if you want to get certified
in this field of business analysis and
want to upskill yourself so here's our
postgraduate program is business analyst
in collaboration with Purdue this is a
comprehensive program designed to equip
Learners with the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as a business
analyst this program is delivered online
and is intended for individuals who want
to learn and enhance their business
analysis skills and Advance their career
in this field the program covers various
topics such as business analysis
Essentials project management data
analysis data modeling and data
visualization using popular tools such
as Microsoft Excel Microsoft power bi
Etc upon completing the program Learners
will receive a certificate from Simply
learn and the skills and knowledge
required to succeed as a business
analyst
they will also have access to Simply
learns Career Services which provide
guidance and support to help Learners
transition into the job market overall
the post-graduate program in business
analysis by simply learn is an excellent
option for individuals who wants to
enhance their business analysis skills
and Advance their career in this field
now let me ask you guys one interesting
question what is the primary goal of
conducting a SWOT analysis option A
identify market trends and customer
preferences option b accessing the
financial viability of a business
venture option C evaluating the internal
and external factors impacting a
business option D developing strategies
for product development and Innovations
please answer in the comment section
below and we will update the answer in
the pin comment you can also pause the
video give it a thought and answer in
the comment section now let's dive back
into our video business analysis is like
being a detective for a company it helps
a company figure out what it needs and
how to make things better business
analysis is done for all sort of things
a company wants to do whether big or
small it can be a part of specific
project or ongoing as the company grows
and improves think of it this way
business analysis helps a company
understand where it is right now where
it wants to go and how it gets there
it's like looking at a map and planning
the best route for a journey it's
important because it helps the company
make smart decision and find ways to
create value for the people involved
so if you are into solving Mysteries and
helping companies grow business analyst
might be the perfect role for you
so till now you must have gotten an idea
of what business analysis is now we will
see who is a business analyst
a business analyst is a person who
performs business analysis tasks
described in a bab okay which is the
business analysis body of knowledge
no matter the job title or
organizational role business analysts
are responsible for discovering and
analyzing information from a variety of
source with an expertise including tools
processes documentations and
stakeholders
now let's see what business analysts do
the activities that business analysts
perform includes business analyst
understanding Enterprise problems and
goals analyzing needs and solutions
formulate strategies Drive changes and
facilitates stakeholders collaboration
moving ahead with the positions that we
have in the business and let's discuss
with the education and skills needed for
the career path let's begin with
discussing the typical salary range of
an entry-level business analyst position
it's important to keep in mind that the
salary figure depends on various factors
such as location industry and Company
size however we can provide a general
idea of what you might expect
for entry-level business analyst in
India the salary range for entry-level
business analyst is typically between 3
lakh to 6 lakh per annum and in the US
the salary range for entry-level
business analyst is approximately
between 50 000 US dollar to 70 000 US
dollar per annum
now let's see education and Foundation
first you will need to get a bachelor
degree in Business Administration
computer science or relatable feed it's
like building a strong Foundation of
your career to boost your credentials
you can also consider getting
certifications after that sharpen your
skills acquire domain knowledge and
develop your analytical skills by
learning tools like Excel SQL and data
visualization software these are like
secret weapons that will help you
analyze data and find important insights
you should also learn problem solving
methods and how the model processes it's
like becoming a problem-solving
superhero now hands-on experience to
really level up look for internships
entry-level positions or projects within
your organization this will give you a
practical experience and allows you to
contribute to the requirements Gathering
documentation and testing it's like
going to on a real life mission and
making a tangible impact by following
these steps you will be well on your way
to become a skilled business analyst you
will be the hero who helps businesses
make smart decision and drive success
now let's talk about senior business
analyst salary
for senior level business analysis in
India the salary range can be between 6
lakh per annum to 12 lakh per annum
in the U.S the salary range of a senior
business analyst is typically between 70
000 US dollar to 100 000 US dollar per
annum for education and Foundation
consider pursuing a master degree in
Business Administration or a relatable
field to depend your knowledge and
expertise explore Advanced certification
such as certified business analyst
professional or project management
professional acquired domain knowledge
continue expanding your understanding of
the industry and its strength challenges
and emerging Technologies develop a deep
understanding or specific business
domain with the industry next analytical
skill development
enhance your data analysis capabilities
by exploring Advanced Technologies
predictive modeling and data
visualization
familiarize yourself with business
intelligence tools and advanced
analytics platforms hands-on experience
take the lead on large projects and
handle critical business analysis
activities mentor and support Junior
analysts provide them with guidance and
assistance remember the key is to
continue learning gaining practical
experience and staying up to date with
the industry trains good luck with your
business analysis Journey after that we
have lead business analyst the salary
range of a lead business analyst in
India can vary from 12 lakh per annum to
25 lakh per annum and in the US the
salary range for lead business analyst
is typically between 100 000 US dollar
to 150 000 US dollar next education and
Foundation take Advanced certification
and specialized training in leadership
and business strategy
you should also acquire domain knowledge
become an expert in your industry by
staying up to date on Trends
regularizing on new technologies next
analytical skills development is very
important develop expertise in advanced
analytics machine learning and
artificial intelligence learn about
tools and Technologies for predictive
analysis and data-driven decision making
next we have business analysis
Technologies Master the art of
facilitating and negotiating in complex
stakeholders engagement
last hands-on experience take the lead
on strategic initiatives and large-scale
projects play a significant role in
shaping your organization's business
analysis processes and methodologies
everyone processes at their own pace
based on their skills opportunities and
Industry demands keep seeking
professional development take on
challenging tasks and build strong
relationship with the industry to
accelerate your growth as a business
analyst I have always been passionate
about any new things and improving my
teaching skills about five years ago I
realized that I have a gap in my
knowledge and to fill the Gap I needed
to skill myself I chose syntry learning
at my upskilling partner because of its
comprehensive curriculum and its
connection with Urdu University
hi my name is Carlos vinares
I live in Lexington in the city of
Kentucky in the United States I am an
assistant professor at Midway University
and I hold a PhD in management human
resources and Leadership I decided to
opt for the post graduation program in
business analysis from Superior which
has helped me a lot to my professional
and personal life I have been teaching
even before I moved to the United States
years ago
I try to use Excel while teaching
research classes
but
since I only had the basic knowledge
about it and other business intelligence
tools it was very difficult for me at
the beginning but after completing this
class and learning how to use tools like
Excel Tableau power bi power query
problem I feel like it has been a total
game changer for me now I apply these
skills everywhere
which has also helped me a lot in my
yearly review I submitted all my
certificates to my university and based
on that my University plans to develop a
class focus on business analysis and
starting in Fall 2023
and I am really excited
when I finally decide to go for an
online program I research a lot
and finally I chose simply learner and I
must say it has been a wonderful
experience
if you see how the business work is
changing now when you're Skilling
yourself is quite essential to keep up
with the change everything works on
numbers now data is more valuable and
important than ever so
I encourage you to keep learning
and keep growing so with this we have
read the end of this video make sure you
like share and subscribe to Simply
learns YouTube channel thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign